When many designers talk about stripes,
they tend to mention how much they stand
out.
The stripe is possibly the most
noticeable pattern,
the immediate and repetitive change from
one color to another,
calls attention to itself,
which explains why caution signs are
almost exclusively striped along with
other things you need to see like
lighthouses signaling flags and the old
fashioned barbershop pole,
and so it's no coincidence that the most
famous cartoon you're always trying to
look for has a striped shirt.
He doesn't blend in the designer of the
IBM logo,
set it right stripes,
attract attention.
The visual power of the pattern possibly
comes from the inability to distinguish
a stripes foreground from its
background.
There's something visually confusing
about the layers of a stripe.
Notice how every optical illusion or
hypnosis video uses stripes.
There's even an evolutionary theory that
zebras wear stripes to confuse
predators,
have their number in distance.
It works so well.
Humans copied the technique for world
war two battleships and remember that
none of these traits apply as strongly
to other patterns.
Checkered feels more orderly.
Plat is less jarring and spots have a
clear foreground and background.
Stripes are the most extreme,
stripes are different,
and these unique properties of stripes
have made them powerful symbols that
have eventually evolve into signs of
oppression,
deviance,
freedom,
and daring style.
No matter where stripes are,
they are never subtle.
My goal for this video is to talk about
the theories of design and symbolism of
the stripe in art history and design and
apply those ideas to the stripes and
movies.
The significance of stripes and cinema
is actually surprisingly under
researched,
but the meaning of stripes in art and
design should apply to movies as well,
if not more so.
Michael,
pastor,
row,
and author of a book on the history of
stripes did have one movie in mind when
discussing the power of stripes
historically spellbound by Alfred
Hitchcock,
stars,
a man with a phobia of lines against a
white background,
a man with an actual fear of stripes.
I doubt a movie could pull that off with
any other pattern and it just goes to
show how the contrast of stripes has
massive appeal to the eye of the
filmmaker.
If stripes can literally be somebody
phobia in a movie,
they must mean something,
but I'm getting ahead of myself.
Historically,
the natural properties of stripes gave
them symbolic meaning in western Europe
and their power at that time can't be
underestimated.
When a Stripe Orange Catholic religious
group came to Europe from the Crusader
states in the twelfth century,
they were ridiculed for how they were
addressed to the point that Pope
Alexander the fourth band,
all clergy men from wearing stripes in
the middle ages when the type of
clothing always indicated your social
status stripes pointed out the deviance
of society.
Anybody who wasn't an honest citizen in
art strike people are more often than
not,
the gestures,
prostitutes,
executioners,
or traders in a twelfth century painting
God gifts Adam and Eve a striped garment
before they are expelled from paradise.
In this case,
the stripes indicate they have committed
acts of shame and sin.
Similarly,
the striped bedding in this 14th
century,
French painting shows the immorality of
what they're doing.
In an era where what you wore with a
clear indication of your social status,
the flashiness of the strike meant you
were a social deviant and its meaning
was taken very seriously.
It was often even associated with
monsters and the devil.
This traditional perception of stripes
made its way into the movies.
Many deviant women in film have worn
stripes.
Maybe the most convincing example is how
the wicked witch of the East is
distinguished only by her boldly striped
black and white stockings.
That same year,
Dallas and stage coach has a similar
stripe moment and she's a prostitute in
the movie,
possibly originating in the penal
colonies of America.
Prisoners also war stripes as a uniform.
Again,
it's a classic sign of the deviant and
movies are no different,
and while the stripe as a badge of shame
continued later centuries introduced
different interpretations of the pattern
starting in the 16th century strikes
shifted from being strictly diabolic
into Tamer.
Eventually positive meanings.
It became a uniform for servants and
found its way on textiles integrating
its way into the home.
Most importantly,
however,
is the American revolution.
Introducing the stripe to flag as a
symbol of rebellion.
They took a pattern used for the
prisoners of the American south and made
it their battle cry,
showing how they felt like prisoners
under British rule.
The French followed suit and from then
on,
those in favor of the movement of
freedom could wear stripes to show their
support.
Really the stripes meaning hadn't
explicitly changed.
It's still a sign of an outsider or a
deviant as the revolutionaries.
Clearly we're,
but it's no longer exclusively negative
movies showed these multiple
interpretations of the strike.
In some cases,
the pattern is a sign of the delinquent
in others.
They are worn on purpose to signal
somebody unique.
The dual meaning of stripes even shows
itself in nature.
A Study of stripes in 2015 mentioned how
many animals use them as a warning to
signal an unpleasant consequence of an
attack while others use stripes to
attract attention from a potential mate,
so stripes can be equally good or bad.
American cinema in the 19 fifties showed
the rebellious meaning of the stripe
coming to the big screen with many high
profile actors wearing the Breton Stripe
in movies directed a teens and young
adults all warned by characters who
don't follow the status quo.
This movement also spread to artists,
philosophers,
and the Ramones,
so what stripes also being worn as a
point of pride,
we see people using stripes to stand out
on purpose.
A classic example is the gangster
gangster is actually wore pinstripes in
real life,
and that style made its way into the
movies.
Gangsters outfits commonly have stripes
to look flashy as they flaunt their
wealth and status to the point that some
of them look tasteless for the most
crooked over the top male characters.
Notice how crazy the stripes become.
The kind of stripe also matters.
Long fixed stripes seem to go to the
flashy characters,
but thin,
sleek,
stripes look more fashionable.
You could make the argument that
filmmakers use bold stripes on
businessmen to make them seem more
crooked,
but stripes can also look very chic.
Old Structure Calls for solid colored or
discretely pattern suits and ties.
The more pronounced the stripe,
the crazier filmmaking has certainly
taken advantage of the disorienting
nature of the stripe.
It's no coincidence that a striped cat
is an illusionist and the introduction
to cycle works because the imbalance of
the stripes looks off like the slicing
of a knife.
There's also a complicated relationship
between stripes,
children and hygiene.
Michelle,
pastor rose,
study of stripes mentions how underwear
into under garments were completely
white because the people of the Middle
Ages saw dice and coloring as a form of
contamination while was pure and
healthy.
As a result,
no color ever directly touch the body in
the 20th century.
However,
the strength became a way to add style
to pajamas,
towels and underwear while keeping some
whiteness in the clothing.
So when the current day,
Prince George always wearing stripes
because it has become a symbol of
hygiene,
but there's also a little bit of the
original meaning of stripes and that
children are playfully deviant,
not quite fitting in with society
completely.
And so some filmmakers do stripes to
evoke a childishness to characters which
is in its own way,
a form of deviance.
Ever since the gestures and jugglers in
the medieval ages,
mankind has had an understanding that
stripes can also look childish,
silly and funny.
Now,
I'm not saying that all the stripes done
in movies were done with knowledge of
the stripes history.
It's actually the opposite.
Nobody had even considered the meaning
or history of stripes until the last
decade or so.
What I'm trying to say is the design of
the stripe naturally causes it to stand
out and so it makes sense that in movies
where wardrobe is meticulously chosen,
filmmakers subconsciously or consciously
used to that extreme change from one
color to the next to tell us something
about the character.
Maybe they're downright evil or they're
a rebellious teen.
Either way,
the stripes helps show they are a
deviant from the status quo in some way,
and movies understand this dual meaning.
Think about the title of the boy in the
striped pajamas.
In one sense,
striped pajamas are a sign of fashion,
comfort and the playful child,
but the audience knows the real reason.
His clothes were striped.
The movie's title plays on our cultures,
multiple interpretations of the Stripe.
Juno is perhaps the most complicated and
effective the use of stripes I've seen
in the movies.
It's the pattern,
Juno,
whereas most often and it became her
symbol in the trailers and poster art.
It fits her character perfectly.
She's playful,
childish,
and stands out with her,
sharp over the top dialogue,
but she's also a deviant as a pregnant
teenager.
She self identifies as rebellious and it
has unconventional taste in music and
style.
She commands attention,
both good and bad and the stripes are
the perfect companion to her character,
but no matter what they're used for,
stripes always stands out.
They may Joseph's coat standout in the
Bible and they compliment Juno's
uncontained,
which we're just starting to see more
research into the symbolism of the
stripe and I invite you to look into it
yourself.
I recently noticed the evil Gremlin is
need stripe and it totally fits with the
original Association of stripes with
monsters and how he's a deviant,
as the Gremlin.
That's the most evil.
I'm sure there are tons of other
examples of stripes and movies out
there.
I haven't come across.
Check out.
Now you see it.blog/stripes to see all
the examples of stripes I have compiled
so far.
If you think of any stripes in movies or
come across any in the future,
there's another link where you can
submit the name of the film,
who wears the stripes and what the
possible meaning might be in the
description.
I'll continue adding screenshots to make
the first compiled collection of stripes
in film available on the Internet.
Graphic designers have understood the
power of stripes for a long time even
before there was any research on them.
The Ibm logo is a famous example,
but you can also look at Adidas,
apple,
and a t and t to see how companies use
stripes to convey speed and going
against the status quo.
Professional logo designers are some of
the few people who do understand the
meaning of the stripe.
One of the premier logo designers in the
business currently is Aaron Draplin,
a designer for Nike Ford,
and even the Obama administration.
If you want to learn the secrets of
great logo design,
you can sign up for his class on
skillshare.
Skillshare has over 20,000 classes on
topics ranging from photography to
business.
The first 500 people to click on the
link in the description below can get
two months of completely free access to
skillshare.
That's the logo design class,
plus thousands of others across
cinematography,
video editing,
photography,
marketing,
and business.
Thanks for watching and a big thank you
to skillshare for sponsoring this video.